[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore
encore j'ai quitté la Galilée pour
revenir en
Galilée j'ai franchi le pays pour m'en
revenir jusqu'ici en Galilée en
Galilée celle du parents j'ai fait le
tour de la terre le ballon de la marche
journalière les cont j'ai ramené mes
chimelles salut parents me voici fortune
fête pas votre enfant qui vous fit
tourner la tête en faisant les
pirouettes tout autour de la planète
ouais ouais j'ai quitté la Galilée pour
revenir en
Galilée j'ai franchi le pays pour m'en
revenir
jusqu'icici en Galé en
galité j'étais parti sur not titane je
reviens dans mon pays sans mat Capitan
de mon carrosse où s'accroche tous les
gosses je parti comme un pauvre
misérable je je rempl d'une fortune
incroyable
[Musique]
able j'ai quitté la Galilée pour revenir
en
Galilée j'ai franchi le pays pour
revenir jusquici en Galilée en
gal c'est bien fin la char sur
lescourage j'ai commandé TR les plus
modern que
casernes
cit j'ai quitté la Galilée pour revenir
en
Galilée j'ai franchi pays pour m'en
revenir jusqu'ici en Galilée en
galiléez les copains venez dans en vacan
V bien parmi des cach d'or qui chanter
des anges les copains dans la ronde des
qui voudra bien le la la main allez c la
musique j'ai quitté la Galilée pour
revenir en
Galilée j'ai franchi mis pays pour m'en
revenir jusqu'ici en Galilée en
[Musique]
Galilée